- You are a, oh, look at this!
What is this, what is this?
How are they?
They're not bad!
(upbeat music)
Hi, I'm Neil Patrick
Harris, and I've been asked
to read questions while
playing with puppies.
And how do you say no to that?
Hi!
You're so cute!
Oh!
Here's a question, what's
one of your weirdest
or funniest fan encounters?
I had an old timey fan
once, he was squeaky.
So then I got one of the newer
Dyson fans, that's better.
If you had to give Count
Olaf one genuine compliment,
what would it be?
He is devilishly handsome.
He has metal, you know what that means?
Not metal like your collar,
but metal, gumption.
What are you plans after the third season,
I'm assuming last season it will catch up
to the last books of A
Series of Unfortunate Events?
And when it wraps filming,
will you go back to Broadway?
Um, that's my lace, of my shoe, thank you.
Um, I'd love to go back
to Broadway some day.
I'm looking forward to resting.
A Series of Unfortunate
Events is super fun,
but all kinds of exhausting,
much like, you know when you
really have to take a dump?
But you can't, because you're not outside?
You know that feeling,
and you really gotta go?
And then you finally go and you're like,
oh I need a rest, that's
kinda my life right now.
Hey question, what's the craziest rumor
you've heard about yourself?
Um, that i was on Malcolm in the Middle.
In a movie about your life, who
would you want to play and David?
Oh, that's a good question,
who would play me?
Josh Dummel, and who would play David?
Nick Jonas, next question!
(laughs)
(soft music)
C'mon, c'mon.
This is my favorite, are we
allowed to pick a favorite?
Because this one, fine,
okay it's the other one.
Fine, it's the other one then.
What in your opinion, was
Count Olaf's best disguise?
They were all pretty good.
I think I like the Detective
DuPaul the best, right?
He's in the bile village episodes.
And he's a hipster man
and he talks like this!
Everything he says boop
da da boop boop, cool.
Is there a celebrity that you've met
that left you completely starstruck?
David Franco.
Easy to look at.
To put it bluntly, Count
Olaf is a garbage human.
How do you get into character to
play such a despicable person?
It's kinda easy because
if your ever grumpy,
or wishing, or if you're
down and negative,
you can just channel
that into the character.
How often do you get to play someone
who is downright awful, answer me!
Do you still talk to the HIMYM cast?
Would you ever consider collaborating
or reuniting with the cast down the line?
I do still talk to the HIMYM
cast, mostly Cobie Smulders,
because when you have kids
that are similar ages,
and she and Taran her husband
lived in New York for a bit,
but yeah we text and shoot the breeze.
I don't think we'd ever
reunite on the show.
Now you are, you are a
troublemaker, yes you are.
Yes, thank you.
These are so cute these dogs.
You played a lot of really
different characters,
do you have a favorite one?
My favorite is probably,
Shirley St. Ives was fun.
She was a girl, and I sorta
got to play a mad man.
She talked like this, it was
less fun when I had to pee.
Because I was wearing padding and spanx.
And kind of tucking, you know.
Do you appreciate it when fans
come up to you in public,
or is it annoying?
No it's never annoying I like fans
when they come up, I like
when people say nice things.
Less fun is when they just
try to take your picture
while you're eating at a restaurant,
because that's never a good picture.
I'm like talking, in the
middle of a conversation,
scowling, I look over, and someones like.
But if someone comes up
and says something nice,
that's always fun to hear, right?
Uh this one, this one, lover boy, girl?
Would you ever host the Tony's again?
Oh I would love to do that again.
It's a hard job though.
Maybe some day, I need
to take some time off.
The Tony's are great fun,
great show for the host.
Because there's all the performances,
it is the best show to watch because
it's all performances by people
who are doing shows live.
So then you get the live
show, all around you.
What did you learn as a young actor
in Doogie Howser, M.D. that
helped you later in life
as an adult actor?
How to suture my own wounds.
How to neuter dogs, that
hasn't helped me that much.
What has been the most
memorable moment in your life
that you would like to cherish forever?
Oh man, the birth of my children.
Holding newborn babies,
that came from you,
that's a pretty amazing thing.
Kids by the way would love you guys.
Thank God they're not here,
because I would be leaving
with four more dogs.
How do you go about choosing the themes
for your family's Halloween
costumes each year?
And can you hint at some
potential options for this year?
No hints, we have talked about it.
It's much more of a
negotiation now because,
the kids speak the English
language and have opinions.
Before it was so much easier, here,
put on this Hawaiian costume,
here you look like Dorothy.
Snap, now it's, c'mon, it'll be fun.
You're gonna do this, you're
gonna wear this, put this on.
No we don't do that.
What do you think happened with
Barney after the show ended,
and what would he be up to now?
Um, probably same old same
old, what would he be up to?
Two fingers of scotch, and probably,
fifteen chicks.
What's your go-to karaoke song?
That's a good question,
Rocket Man is good.
I tend to go with Elton John
songs, because they're fun.
I also know all the words to
The Devil went down to Georgia.
That was my New Mexico rap days.
He was in a bind, because
he was way behind.
He was willing to make a deal,
when he came across the Joe Man's song,
we're still gonna play it hot!
What's your idea of a perfect day?
Playing with puppies.
Or probably a perfect day would be,
with my family, in Hawaii,
on the beach, drinking a
pina colada, and writing
Disney theme park attractions.
I don't think there's a
Disney theme park in Hawaii,
but that would be a perfect day.
Okay, that's my arm, thank you.
Out of all the villains in
Count Olaf's theater troupe,
who is your favorite?
I got a soft spot for Hook Hand Man,
because he is my right hook man.
Last question, if you were willingly going
to visit a deserted island for a few days
and could only have three things with you,
what would you bring?
Three things on a deserted island.
A lighter, or a tarp, one of those phones,
that you can call people that saves you.
Luxury items I'd probably
bring, I don't know, a ukulele?
No, he said no I'm biting his shoe.
Um, maybe a flashlight.
Alright, those are all
my questions, thank you
for asking them, and thanks
for all these puppies
who are all available if you
want to own one of these,
they're all from the
North Shore Animal League.
So thanks to the amazing people there
for doing that, and come give yourself an
angry, biting dog, ow!
(laughs)
See ya.
(soft music)